hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry welcome
to reason [ __ ] calm where we give you
reasons to see and not to see whatever
movie we're reviewing so let's hang out
it may not feel like a necessary reboot
but for what it is it's still a
fantastic film
Ryan's consensus there are a lot of
reasons to watch the amazing spider-man
there are a lot of reasons to watch the
amazing spider-man
I am bloated okay yeah Jerry's consensus
there are a lot of reasons to watch the
minutes but there are a lot of reasons
to watch the amazing spider-man he's
back he's back he's back so he's been
sort of sort of that he's sort of that
yeah reason to see number one a new
Peter Parker
it's like rebel without a cause means
spider-man in a way all I really want to
have this was was something different
you know I just wanted a different type
of Peter Parker you know different
spider-man story and and I I feel like
we got that you know Peter Parker that's
when he's very intelligent he's a loner
but he's not a nerd so in this one like
Peter Parker he he seems more losses and
he's more emotionally confused and when
he becomes spider-man it's a little
unintentional in the first one it seems
like he's doing justice in this one it's
like he's taking out his [ __ ] on the bad
guys it's like he's gonna mess with them
first sort of like a therapeutic release
yeah the vigilante he's becoming at
first is a criminal but now he has to
make the choice is he gonna be a
criminal or is he gonna be a hero if I
had spider-man's powers and I had some
[ __ ] bully picking on me I would
totally use my powers like him reason to
see number two franchise improvements I
honestly was not expecting I love this
movie this much I was against this movie
yeah no I mean I think I was even more
sure that you or
yes movie yeah which is rare so you know
in the original like the Sam Raimi so I
remove everything sort of happens by
chance you know it's like on a normal
day you know the spider came down you
know and and then this is one that seems
like everything time intertwine do you
know everything happens you know he goes
to the museum that because he wants to
know more about his parents and there he
sees the spiders which is parents work
out like it's all connected this time
it's all linked in this one it really
seems like Peter Parker gets himself
into the situation if they wanted to do
spider-man part four
they would not have been able to
continue the franchise by making it like
this if they wanted to make a film that
was darker more greedy more realistic it
would have just been too much for an
audience to handle for a part for yeah
that's how people do you know reboots
now it's like it's going to be darker
you have any more serious
nobody ever nobody ever makes a reboot
and be like let's make it wacky and fun
like wait let's make it much lighter
everyone shaved you know the problem
with a lot of comic book movies is there
are too many storylines like spider-man
three that want suck the biggest fattest
balls right in this one there's a lot of
multiple storylines yet they all seem to
fit they all seem to work just right
reason to see number thirty Andrew
Garfield kind of has a you know a James
Dean thing going on he's got a lot more
wisecracks this time you know sort of
like the comic he's got a lot of sarcasm
in the first trilogy there's like
spider-man and there's Peter Parker but
in this one whenever Spiderman steps
onto the screen you can still be Landru
Garfield's presence you really feel like
you're in Peter Parker shoes there's
like an emotional transference happening
where you're feeling what would Andrew
Garfield's feeling then it feels gritty
reason to see number four that Musto and
gwen stacy mana him emma stone is
perfectly cast she's different from mary
jane every stone is gonna be a high
school for like the rest of her gonna be
sixty is dope like high school
reason to see number five romance
there's a great romantic story going on
here the chemistry between Andrew
Garfield and Emma
stone is is magical unlike how I felt to
the first trilogy I found the romance in
this movie to be absolutely essential to
the story they don't spend forever in
this one making a romantic build up you
know because rainy already took care of
that and this one it's great to see
spider-man in a relationship with
someone who's not a superhero and still
trying to lead a romantic life I know
they tried doing that with spider-man 3
but honestly Mary Jane just came across
like a whiny little [ __ ] oh and the way
Peter Parker reveals how he's spider-man
- endless tone I would totally do that
yeah that's like the ultimate like
you're the man okay yeah it's like who's
the biggest [ __ ] right now he's in the
sea number 6 dr. Connors aka it's a
great villain because to him that makes
sense what he's doing it's like he's
giving a gift to the world there's a lot
of purpose
nothing is credit Willem Dafoe's
performance but he was sort of like you
[ __ ] and then spider-man randomly
gets involved he's not as fun to watch
some of the other villains in the prior
trilogy but he's still a fantastic
villainy reason to see number 7 the
supporting cast
I love Martin Sheen's performance in
this one yeah well you really is you
could you can feel the father figure and
you know in his performance in this one
it's like they know they're not his
parents they're trying to be his parents
but they're not and there's that whole
there that they can't necessarily fill
so that's a different dynamic to the
family even anime is more interesting
has more motion going on and I like how
Aunt May Kaunas might possibly know that
he's spider-man yeah I got a point on
Captain Stacy in this film ya know he's
definitely a highlight he comes in late
but he comes in just at the right time
yeah totally and it's great to see him
not just playing a douchebag but you
know a cop with some purpose well you
actually understand you know why he's
upset about spider-man is the reason to
see number 8 Marc Webb's direction Marc
Webb I didn't think the guy could do it
sure there are some similarities to the
prior trilogy but those are the things
that you have to
because it's part of spider-man's origin
it's like having a Batman movie without
showing that his parents died I loved
his choice to make it a lot more
grounded a lot more realistic it feels
like the real world you know it's gritty
you know you get the sense for New York
it's fun in a lot of ways but it's not
cartoonish no it's not to like cartoon
reason to see number nine though right
the writing this movies really tightens
everything ties into Peter Parker
somehow like every story event is
directly related to him you can feel
that things are really not going well
for the guy one of the things I thought
they executed very well was the law
enforcement well yeah that's the one
thing no one ever thinks about these
superhero movies is like oh like the
police actually do things aside from
just arrest people like they actually
have strategy and like if you mess up
their strategy and then they can't catch
criminals and it messes up their
operation so they explain that really
well it's a cool thing to touch up and I
like how they're not just crooked cops
again yeah a little bit he's having to
balance high school life and being Peter
Parker the Peter Parker drama is
actually very interesting which
magnifies it when he becomes spider-man
I can completely identify with Peter
Parker even though sometimes he does
those things the teenagers do that make
them frustrating and somewhat unlikable
and you get hit yeah actually makes it
more understanding I'm not watching it
for an hour going I wanna get to
spider-man are ya every single character
in this film has a character arc it
doesn't seem like some forced [ __ ]
character growth going on even though
it's dark it's still pretty fun in the
first one when he [ __ ] with flash he's
kind of doing it all by accident and
this one it's hilarious because I would
absolutely do that a and B it's
intentional reason to see number 10
action
when it comes to action and visual
effects this film delivers because you
can feel Peter Parker underneath that
suit when he spider-man and he fights
those criminals you kind of feel like
you're fighting the criminals too it's
awesome the movie has great visual
effects I mean there are a couple bum
moments but for the most part I mean it
looks spectacular watch it in 3d reasons
not to see so the reasons not to see
today aren't exactly reasons not to see
so much as they're just not necessarily
reasons to see reason not to see number
one the bully the bully with flash the
little heightened it's like are there
any adults at this go at all it's a
little hard to accept that in this day
and age bullying is that over-the-top
and it's kind of hard to accept the
bullying in this film for a film that's
going for a lot more realism yeah
reasons not to see number two obvious
similarities the way how Norman Osborn
becomes the Green Goblin is sort of
similar to the way how he becomes the
lizard in this film yeah it's like you
know we can't give you money for testing
a longer arm test on me then like you
know he talks to himself he has a split
personality and some of the familiar
plot points feel a little too rush but
really gives a [ __ ] we already saw a
reason not to see number three too many
mentors I'm pretty sure almost every
character in this film is somehow a
mentor to Peter Parker at least once
even the guy at the convenience store
there's much good it's like kid you
really ought to you know it seems like
everyone wants to be Peter Parker's dad
even they got at the convenience store
he's like son let me come here and I'll
buy you no reason not to see number four
Sony productions
if you're really looking for a reason
not to like this movie just bag on Sony
yeah scene stuff
earns me a little bit but you know for
once you get in the runtime of the
actual
which is what's important you know I
mean so many kind of stung spider-man
itself I don't think we'll ever know the
true story of what's going on yeah I
mean it's all tied up in the [ __ ]
reason not to see number five no getting
out this very much
this episode of real reasons to scene
was paid for by the Ryan charity
foundation from all bruised camel cameos
every movie and television show ever
made association with Liberty moved six
row